[Applause]
hold it
and i have a diagonal so i'm not over
like this
there's a diagonal to my torso
midfoot balance
okay okay so
my my foot my foot width is the same
foot width
of dead lift under under my hips or
shoulder press
my torso angle is the same torso angle
as the back squat
so no no not like that because i'm
trying to engage my rear posterior thing
so that's what i'm doing
get my feet you see then
back angle back squat
and whatever you can grab onto i want
you to grab onto
so i have some resistance that i have to
deal with
okay so
nice and slow
see how i'm holding him up to stress my
posture
okay let's go
[Music]
okay so he's gonna do the technique and
my my drill is to feel good
is to feel this just to feel that
i don't want my hemi to start being uh
you go into victim mentality
now i'm gonna feel this this energy
right here feel it
can you see what i'm doing do i feel it
don't worry about me
so much of your uh
why you go over is because you you start
finding it
you make yourself throwable so
in the same way like the technique
yesterday
uh he's pushing this is what i use
that's what i use to do the throw
[Music]
so i'm going to use his hip his hips
pushing on me
use this hip
i just got to keep the ground path
[Music]
except
you